you guys haven't had like Jehovah
Jehovah Witnesses come to your door uh
in Australia I did yeah in Japan no
Japan do they exist in Japan I didn't
know they existed until one like Turned
outside my door because you've got a
you've got a nice looking house yeah
yeah I live in a shark dude and then
like I opened the door and they're like
oh can we uh sell you on the word of
Jesus uh and I was like yeah yeah well
they saw me and they had like a like a
Japanese guy and a foreign woman and as
soon as I said sorry I'm a Buddhist the
the girl looks at me and goes do I know
you from somewhere and I was like no uh
no probably just a mistake and I just
shut the door as quickly I was like you
should have been like what's your Source
I also have the vial
I was like oh no I'm just I'm just
another I'm just another just Asian
bloke living in Japan oh I don't know
what you're talking about I didn't know
they existed in Japan yeah I didn't know
either Asian people
hello welcome to another episode of
trash taste I am your host for today
Gant with me again are the boys uh I
didn't realize we'd already started our
pre-talk but hey Jehovah's Witnesses and
almost getting doxed so uh yeah what a
strong opener what a strong opening but
uh I went to a haunted house yesterday
oh they saw a haunted house experience
oh wait uh yeah because it was Sydney's
birthday right yeah yeah
huh what was it called I can't remember
what it was called it was a scary house
something along those lines but Sydney
was like I've wanted to go to this
haunted house it's been made by uh and
this is like my husband's listening
skills coming along it was made by some
guy who was famous for doing some ghost
stories in Japan and I was like okay
honey we can go you know our junji maybe
if it was Junior no no no not Junito
okay okay I would know there's another
theme is junji yeah oh he's like a
Japanese like TV presenter who like got
famous because uh he told like a bunch
of like really scary stories and he's
like a really good narrator or something
rather and I think if I remember
correctly he also like did like a side
gig where he like produced haunted
houses or something like this is my
mental bookmark to talk about the
jinjutu anime after your name
didn't tell the story all right we can
we can talk about about that afterwards
but uh yeah I went to and well we went
to uh Tokyo Dome and because there's
like a whole kind of like amusement park
there and we've never really I I heard
that what there was a lot of things to
do at Tokyo dome but I never had gone
there to explore what everything there
is to do to do around there the only
thing I know about it is that it was one
of the places that uh that guy took
chizuru in rent a girlfriend and I was
just like that's all I knew about it so
all I knew about it was the ferris wheel
you're one of those people yes yes okay
Joey I'm one of those people okay I know
this place was an anime it was in rent a
girlfriend oh my God it's just like real
life yeah but uh they had recently
opened a haunted house experience there
and I don't know you guys like kind of
haunted house haunted house video
recently where I went to yeah yeah yeah
one of the biggest ones right yeah I
think it's the oh I can remember because
I was like it's the biggest and they
were like actually it's the second
please understand the video I think I
think it's like the second biggest 100
and that's right 40 50 minute long oh
[__] haunted house [__] hell yeah
mine was like three floors of a hospital
Jesus Christ okay I gotta take Sydney
there because mine this one I went to in
Tokyo Dome was only about like 10 15
minutes
um and it was you know I'm I'm not
really like okay I'm gonna say right
outright I'm a [__] [__] okay to
join the club I hate I just hate the
feeling of being scared and I've never
understood talk to the choir I've never
understood people who just love horror
movies they just go to horror movies
they love being scared I feel like
there's like two feelings I love the
feeling of being unsettled you know like
that's why I love jinjito works but I
hate the feeling of just feeling jump
scared little jump scared or like
someone's going to kill me you know I
love ideas that make my mind unsettled
but I hate just the fight or flight
reaction right yeah just the direct
horror feeling yeah um and that's
basically everything I experience in a
haunted house I was that guy who would
hate going to any haunted house you the
only reason I went to this one was
because it was Sydney's birthday I was
trying to be a girl that's a good
husband right under any other
circumstance I I ain't going into this
[__] so so paint the scene like what
what kind of like theme was it okay so
it was kind of like The Grudge kind of
kind of thing so they had they had did
yours have like an entire storyline as
well I think it did okay so this this
was did he listen to it yeah
I'll be honest I kind of like wasn't
paying too much attention to the
cutscene myself but the kind of the
basic premise was there was this couple
and the guy cheated on the girl okay and
uh obviously the girl was mad so I
believe that even though the guy cheated
on the girl uh he worked with his side
hoe to just murder the [__] and uh he
came back and uh buried them and he is
his they did a like a five IQ move they
buried them underneath a katatsu that's
and I don't know why you would bury I
don't know why you would bury the girl
in your own well I know it's like
negative yeah I know I know Japan
Japanese houses have like small
backyards but I'm pretty sure it's still
big enough to bury your body yeah right
right and so obviously they got cursed
and uh they for wow what a shocker they
got cursed and uh to remove the curse
um the I believe the girl that uh he
cheated on with uh no matter what she
did she she had a half her face was like
burnt off with a curse or something like
that and you had to apply makeup to to
the girl to remove her curse and that
was that was setting the scene that was
the uh that was kind of like that was
like kind of like the final object like
crayon you gotta like what do you you
got it you got to do this yeah collect
the mascara yeah yeah so you have to
like uh there was some makeup and you
have to like puff like the girl's face
with makeup too
so yeah that was the basic premise of
the haunted house
I've never done a Japanese haunted house
experience before because my experience
with haunted houses were kind of like
just in like America or the UK you kind
of either sit on a cart or you uh kind
of just walk through and it's not really
any storyline it's just kind of like
here are some jump scares here's here's
a bat that flies out of nowhere yeah you
know
um so I I did enjoy the fact that there
was this entire narrative that they kind
of took you through from like the
beginning of like you you saw the entire
murder kind of like take place you saw
them hide the body and then kind of like
the entire the entire process of the
girl coming out haunting them and then
also like kind of like killing them and
so the entire house becomes slowly more
and more haunted as it goes along what I
did like about it was that there weren't
too many jump scares there was there was
like two jump scares out the entire
thing and it was like kind of like and
then the entire floor was just booked
out and every room had a different
different
piece of the storyline and halfway
through you know you you find
you find the girl which is obviously
just a mannequin of the girl and uh you
have to pamper her face with her uh with
the makeup and I was just like I've seen
this movie before Sydney you do it you
do it Sydney
I'm gonna die if I do it I I ain't gonna
be that dude that dies I ain't touched I
ain't going near that face yeah I was
expecting like the biggest kind of jump
scare when you like touch her face I I
think that was a fake out because
actually I I don't want to spoil too
much I guess but actually like uh that
that wasn't where the jump scare was
because I was like [__] myself being
like I was like when Sydney touches the
faces Something's Gonna [__] happen
something loud noise or something loud
noise something but nothing and because
there wasn't a jump scare I don't know
if that was worse or better you know
because you know when you expect a jump
scare and it doesn't happen
um that's that's like it it there's a
part of your emotion that's just like
some something's off here it's it's
gonna come later
but uh one thing I noticed is that
everyone working in this haunted house
just was so friendly and had the biggest
smile on their faces and I could kind of
see why afterwards because of the the
biggest jump scare so most of this
haunted house was made with animatronics
right most most of the characters and
the ghosts were just different
animatronics and it was it was like yeah
it's kind of not that scary yeah it's
it's it's kind of junky I mean I should
have known when I saw the ride and it
was like anyone six and over can come
into this haunted house and I was like
if it's like if it's suitable for a
six-year-old how how back could it be
but there was one moment where where
though it did involve I guess a real
person okay right and I guess this
person's job was just to come out of
this one point of the haunted house and
just scare the [__] out of people and
I'm like honestly that sounds like a
really fun [__] job yeah right you're
basically just Sully from Monsters yeah
that's literally like you're like yeah
yeah I also want someone to watch that
movie he's like damn that that doesn't
sound like that was fun yeah yeah yeah
yeah
so like right at the end you're
presented with like this big statue and
it's like oh it's just another janky
animatronic then out of [__] nowhere
appears the only human or ghostly thing
that you've seen this entire uh this
entire thing and yeah it scared the [__]
out of me because I wasn't expecting a
real like human being luckily luckily
like they didn't touch you or they
didn't grab you or anything because I
swear to God I wouldn't I would have
punished yeah I think my survival is
when it comes I don't know when
everyone's safety they don't touch yeah
I would have liked just get close to you
yeah they got really pretty close but
that but that's what I like about like
especially like Japanese horror right
it's because it's like it's that whole
thing of like you know not expecting the
unexpected right of of the whole thing
of like oh they set it up to be like a
jump scare coming up in this particular
scene get ready for it and then they
don't give it to you yeah and then what
that leaves you with is this like
unsettling feeling of just being on the
edge of your seat the entire time being
like well [__] if it's not on the
obvious spot yeah then where the [__] is
it yeah right and I think that's why
like as much as I don't like horror
movies or like horror games and stuff
like that I [__] with a lot of like
Japanese horror like movies because
they're so they're so good at that like
that building that's just like the
original Ring movie you've seen that one
yeah yeah like there's the one scene
where they just like there's this music
building up and it's like slowly zooming
in and like you know horror movie tropes
yeah there's gonna be a jump scare at
the end of it yeah but then there's no
nothing and so what that does is that it
leaves you hanging and just goes well
[__] now I don't know where the jump
scare is and I'm afraid the entire time
even through scenes that where they're
just casually talking right right and I
feel like you know that's what you kind
of experienced in that Japanese haunted
house because I was kind of the same
like I've been to like one or two
haunted or I was dragged into one or two
haunted houses in Australia yeah and
it's like yeah here comes a zombie oh
here comes another thing oh here comes
something popping out of the closet yeah
yeah it's like all right well they're
normally like on the back of trucks yeah
right right or they're like the carnival
things yeah folded out oh yeah like I
don't know how they make it but like
they're like really quick it's like six
dudes just shout at you I could you know
and I could have just gone home and got
that yeah right you know you gotta here
yeah yeah but the the one in Fuji Q is
really good I think it's like that's the
scariest one right it was [__] it was
insane yeah like I had never been to a
haunted house where I felt thought like
every single detail was is kind of off
the chart is that the one where it's
like every five minutes there's an
emergency exit in case people want to
yeah every five minutes
were you scared going through it I mean
like the jump scares are kind of scary
um I was definitely Hamming it up for
the camera I obviously of course I'd
have to say that but like I I you know
it's a kind of a boring video if I'm
just like kind of casually going so yeah
like all right this is cool I mean like
you you know there's only like a few
ways they can really scare you I I was
more like I was just super impressed
with like the detail and also how kind
of [__] up it got like there's rooms
with like dead babies yeah torn open and
like bodies like full [__] up like
yeah did Kojima produce this it's true
it's no joke you go into this one room
because it's like an abandoned Hall I
think the whole the story they said I
didn't listen to it I mean it was in
Japanese and also I was trying to mess
with the camera to work yeah um and also
we weren't allowed to film the story but
I mean you know the story generally was
like some people went to this hospital
it was abandoned and they went to go see
it and then they got lost in there and
they're all going in again um and and
like dude it was like I imagine if you
like haunted houses this is probably
like the Apex oh yeah like this was like
imagine like a whole Hospital they'd
kind of they just built this building
and every single room was insanely well
like themed and built uh even like the
office rooms were terrifying yeah and I
was like holy [__] the dust is off the
charts I'm gonna contract something but
like it was it was crazy I mean if
Sydney like the one and two I'm sure
she'd loved one in Fuji Q yeah you'd
have to book it I think separate from
your ticket and in advance right oh it's
kind of annoying because it's like you
get the ticket and then you pay another
16 bucks to go into this just the
haunted house and they said it's like
well like an hour experience right
um if you're fast I imagine it can be
like 20 30 but if you're taking a sweet
time originally it's like I've seen park
rides yeah I'd rather take my sweet time
especially in Haunted House experience
because yeah I mean like yeah I've seen
my video it's crazy it's so crazy yeah I
mean I would love to I mean I wouldn't
love to but I'm sure Sydney would I
don't know why she loves horror movies
so [__] much I swear she's watching a
new horror movie every day
I don't know how she finds so many
horror movies I didn't even know there
were this many horror movies being made
but at this point she should just like
start a series where you can review [__]
horror movies like she's probably seen
so many now yeah but apparently in
America it's like a big like [__]
massive thing even like a lot of like
low budget ones that are being made
there's an entire stream service
dedicated just horror movies I'm like
okay like what's the are we in the past
like 10 years how many good horror
movies have we had like two right like
we had like um what's good ones they're
fine okay here's the thing I genuinely
don't know how I would Define a good
horror movie I also don't watch horror
so this is coming from a guy who doesn't
watch horror movie judging yeah yeah
what was the one that came out that was
really [__] good like five six years
ago um that'd like a really good budget
[__] I forgot what it's called I only
came out of the video games now
um uh I've I personally liked hereditary
that was the one hereditary yeah yeah uh
yeah I hated that that [__] me up
right yeah yeah it [__] me up but at
least what I appreciate about hereditary
and just Aries to films in general like
also Midsummer as well was like an
awesome [__] watch that yeah it was
weird yeah I watched Midsummer but it's
like I liked it because it's like yes
it's scary but it's also just [__]
weird yeah and it's like a trip of a
movie yeah and it's like the way that
like they scare it in in those movies
especially is like I love that he
doesn't rely on jump scares like in
hereditary maybe there's like
two jump scares at most that I can
remember but like those aren't the
scariest moments of the movie like the
scariest moments are the really quiet
moments of the movie I I couldn't finish
that movie actually well I I finished
it's probably better because the last 10
minutes were [__] weird yeah I I
finished Midsummer that was still like
unnerving and like scary but you know it
didn't [__] me up I remember there was
this one scene in uh hereditary it
happened like pretty early on but uh
yeah yeah I mean without spoiling
exactly what happens there was there was
a scene involving a mother that was just
screaming and crying oh yeah and that
was like such a guttural scream I lit it
it kind of like induced in me PTSD that
I guess I didn't even know I had because
I've I've never experienced what the
mother is
oh
but it was like no that was it is to the
point where I was like this is like too
well acted yeah well I feel like I I was
so good in that yeah she was she was she
was so good she was so good that I
couldn't finish it because I was like
this this is getting to a point of real
to the point where I'm like I feel like
I'm seeing something I shouldn't be
seeing now I think it was yeah yeah I
don't know because I have no memory of
anything ever
um Bird Box great
did you watch that one box which one
when everyone did the bird box
you remember this movie I never watched
it I saw the memes of it yeah what is
that movie about so dude because I saw
the memes of like everyone blindfolded
because it was crazy because it's just
like blue I can't even [__] bringing
this [__] movie out but this was like
a like a [__] big horror film yeah uh
did you watch it I didn't watch it oh my
God is this okay again this is like a
four-year-old memory of me explaining a
movie I didn't really like that much so
like there was just a monster that came
I can't remember why and it would only
kill you if you like looked at it
oh
um so it's the opposite of the Weeping
Angels yeah yes sir yeah and then like I
guess throughout the movie obviously
people look at it and I guess people go
crazy and they're like I have to look at
it and then and then all I have in
memory now is like okay one it was it
was it was terrible yeah yeah and uh
everyone doing the Stupid Bird Box
challenge which was just people just
walking around blindfolded which is just
like okay you mean being blind is a
challenge now
all right okay blind people could see
this yeah okay yeah and then I remember
there was another thing where like so in
the movie you never see the uh the thing
that's killing everyone you never see it
yeah and then afterwards I don't know if
it was like a joke or what they were
like hey this is what it was actually
gonna look like and it looked like ass
it was like the shittiest looking thing
there's a there's another movie with a
similar premise where like the thing
that's killing everyone uh you know
can't be seen do you guys watch The
Happening no
wait what's that one it's the [__]
movie where it's like uh who who was in
that movie again I think it was Mark
Wahlberg I think was that the enlight
Shyamalan movie I think oh was it I
don't remember but like I only watched
like the first third of that movie Okay
so [__] but basically the the general
promise from what I can remember is like
there's this thing like the next 40
minutes there's three dudes who don't
watch horror
yeah it's like it's like this movie
where like uh Mark Wahlberg is like
people are just like mysteriously dying
from this phenomena that no one can see
and they call it the happening yeah they
just like all these people are dying
what's happening and then Mark Wahlberg
[__] runs around trying to figure it
out and again I don't know how it ends
yeah it was like mean to [__] because it
was so bad but um oh I remember this
yeah yeah yeah I have not just seen it I
know the entire plot of that film just
for people complaining about them
actually have you seen have you seen
unfriended yes
unfriended is where there's like I
believe I don't can't remember if it's
Zoom or if this was before okay yeah
like it's like the opposite of
everything British yeah yeah yeah and
it's just a bunch of it's just like a
ghost killing people on Skype and it's
just like can they hang up no you cannot
hang up your Skype call for some reason
and they just all die one by one uh okay
I'm gonna like I'm okay out of the
horror movies that I've seen with Sydney
I'm gonna try and recommend some good
ones but again again I know what counts
as a good horror movie but these ones
these are ones that I found was
interesting uh so one that was that I
found pretty interesting pretty recently
I don't even know if it counts as a
horror movie it's more like a horror
satire uh it's called the menu oh yeah
yeah have you seen that one uh yeah I
have yeah it's really good yeah yeah
that that was so rough no not real fine
um what the [__] is there are fans
no the main actor the British guy I
can't remember the one featuring the
girl from Queen's game yeah the the girl
from Queen's game that's the one that's
the one so I love how we collectively
know that yeah so basically fines right
am I crazy can you go right yeah yeah
thank God he's the girl so basically
it's kind of like a horror satire of the
whole fine dining kind of culture it's
basically like what mailing yeah it's
basically Battle Royale but like in a
setting of what Malin sees in her Mind's
Eye yeah you know yeah genuinely yeah
Google review is trying to kill each
other
imagine if you saw the world away
millions of the world yeah yeah yeah
that's that's what it is right and so
the main character gets invited to this
prestigious one-of-a-kind fine dining
restaurant that's set on an island uh
and it's just like the most prestigious
menu that's ever going to be served uh
and weird [__] starts happening okay uh
they like you know how you know it's
fine dining is basically just the art
world but with food so so it's it kind
of goes beyond just serving good food
it's all about the story of the food and
so you know you and at first the um the
chef comes out and he presents each dish
that has a different story behind it and
then the story just progressively gets
more and more [__] up until you kind
of slowly realize what's really going on
behind the scenes here and I'm not gonna
spoil what goes on behind the scenes but
let's just say the reviews are very good
as well yeah yeah it was actually a
genuinely good uh good good story and I
think this is okay this is what I think
is my personal way and the best way to
experience horror movies for me is to
not watch horror movies but to watch
YouTube summary of horror movies I'm I'm
that guy I think I watched unfriended
the same way the first time yeah through
YouTube videos I thought there's no way
to [__] to make it happen yeah I mean I
I watched all the Saw movies just from
all those videos of like what's the
possibility of escaping a sword trap
okay here okay so bad before people
clown on me let me let me sell it to you
okay I get to experience the horror
movie because one one of the things one
of the things I think is very
interesting about horror movies is the
mystery aspect okay every horror movie a
lot of I love horror movies even the
[__] ones they have like really
interesting Concepts that kind of like
draw you into like what's scary going on
behind the scenes you know so what's
what [__] up thing is this horror
movie about and 90 of them it's it's a
dumb twist or it's a or like once you
uncover the mystery it's a dumb it's a
dumb mystery and you're like [__] I just
spent an hour and a half for a really
stupid reveal so like the best way for
me to reveal uh to to consume it is just
to watch YouTube summaries which means I
don't have to be scared and I get
presented with a lot of interesting
ideas from all these different horror
movies and I don't have to wait an hour
and a half to uh to kind of like fully
realize if the reveal is worth it you
might as well just [__] read the
Wikipedia at that point you know what
maybe I will Joey maybe I will you just
should read the Wikipedia go to the IMDb
page watch the trailer while reading the
synopsis there you go I don't know why
it's specific horror movies why I just
love watching stories of them they're
[__] up another throwback to the
entire but that hospital hentai was the
horror horror thing in in years it
scared me tomorrow I was scared yeah
definitely but a genuine horror movie
that I did enjoy that is a horror movie
horror movie is I believe the name is As
Above Down Below As Above So Below
something along the one in the French
catacombs the one yeah the French
catacombs yeah it was yeah it was pretty
good it's very like Blair Witch is it
like people get lost in the catacombs
and they're saying stuff okay yeah yeah
yeah yeah just think which but in the
French category yeah yeah they get they
get lost in the catacombs but things
start happening and uh they find out
weird things and there is a reason why
all these things happen which is what I
liked about it is it it was less about
the jump scares but and it was more
about the unnerving idea ideas of what
they found in the catacombs you know um
and that's why I like French people
wasted
yeah there is nothing more terrifying
I've been finding French people on the
ground honestly I I would uh I mean I
would just off myself at that point you
know just being stuck underground with
French people okay I'm done I'm done
oh man I'm trying to think do you like
Paranormal Activity no no I I watched
the first paranormal activity on a plane
you know that's the best one right the
first one out of like the seven that's
the best one
yes I fell asleep in like 20 minutes you
should watch some of the other ones wow
they're very funny oh really they're
really funny like look I get the whole
thing of like oh it was you know it was
a really low budget film and Steven
Spielberg liked it so we greenlit it and
blah blah blah but like I'm just like
bro I'm just like live leak is scarier
than this [__] like it's just [__]
yeah
I don't know like I think the problem
with Paranormal Activity was that like
it was trying to sell you on like the
realistic aspect but it's like okay I
get it you know using the security
camera footage and all that kind of [__]
but it's like if I know it's a movie
yeah then it's just like immediately
less scary yeah the scariest thing about
like The Blair Witch was you know back
in the day before the internet there was
you know there were rumors around that
this wasn't actually a movie yeah but it
was actually just real fast footage and
I feel like having that Mystique to it
that's what made it scary because if you
actually watch The Blair Witch knowing
that it's a film I think gets a lot less
scary knowing that you know this is a
film that was produced and filmed and
scripted rather than oh my God we just
found like a tape and we don't know what
it is you know and we're gonna put it in
the cinemas anyway yeah I I feel like
that must yeah you know you know what
don't give it to the police look we were
a lot dumb up back then okay a lot of
the Mystique has gone thanks to the
internet now but you might not remember
this but you know as you know when
growing up in the before the edge of the
internet things like this could exist
like I remember what was it like
Cannibal Holocaust or something oh yeah
like didn't like the director of that
get arrested because people actually
thought it was real it was actually
[__] real yeah and you know I'd heard
that there were some horrendous things
happening on set of that film anyway but
you know it wasn't a snuff film yeah
yeah exactly thankfully enough I would
actually say that like as much as I
don't like horror films B grade horror
films uh so [__] fun to watch because
it's like immediately just from the
scuffed nature of it it just becomes
more satiric goal and actually in a lot
of ways actually it's really
entertaining and funny the best B grade
horror film I ever watched was do you
know this movie called Dead Sushi no no
what is that so it was it was made by
this guy called takashimike who's like
the most like
okay he's like the most infamous
Japanese director
um but it's one of his he made like a
[__] load of B grade horror films but
it's 11 pretty [__] up and a lot of
them are [__] up yeah uh I think he
actually used to like direct porn before
he did that which is hilarious but like
that's one of the ones uh that Aki
showed me it's essentially just this
like story of I'm trying to remember
because it's been a while but it's
essentially like there's this like
female lead who is uh you know goes to
like a sushi establishment because she
wants to like learn the craft of like
you know making sushi and stuff like
that yeah and I think something along
the lines of like some like radioactive
waste uh spills onto some sushi and then
the sushi come alive and start killing
people very sausage party but generally
yeah basically and it's like it's
basically these like this she but like
they grow teeth and [__] and they're
just like and they just [__] fly
through the air and kill people it's so
Jank and but it's so hilarious and
entertaining and like there's a couple
of scenes where it's like genuinely
unnerving because it's a meme film right
like he gets really boring with his
films
um I think he was the one that made um
what is it audition that like really
[__] up like yeah like film yeah that
was probably his most famous yeah that's
his most famous one but like it's it's
not as bad as that one but um yeah he
basically was just like what would
happen if Sushi came back soon
yeah and then I'll make audition as well
it's one of those [__] up films ever
made I Feel Like We Tour this I unlocked
the core memory yeah I was like I
remember I talked to Sydney about horror
film and I think me and uh you're ready
to Alan had watched uh
a horror movie together on Netflix and
we both thought it was like really
[__] stupid and funny and then Sydney
was talking about it like a month later
I was like yeah it's actually the this
is one of my favorite horror films of
all time it's amazing and I just you
know it tells him and I was like oh oh
we watched that differently yeah it was
called uh cam
it's a horror film came out on Netflix
five years ago and um it was about like
a cam girl but I think the cam girl goes
like I can't remember oh I remember her
talking about like the cam girl goes
live and she's seeing herself go live as
the cam guy yeah yeah yeah and I can't
remember
every Eagles worst nightmare honestly I
remember her talking about this and I'm
just like this sounds like a pretty
interesting concept especially in in
this day and age where I I think uh so
what as Connor said there's a cam girl
that you know makes money doing cam girl
stuff but then like she wakes up one day
and she just sees herself
in a live stream live broadcast I don't
know if it's this one I'm reading the
plot I'm like what the [__] is probably
this one right it is that one yeah yeah
that's crazy look at the difference
between the IMDb and the Rotten Tomatoes
IMDb 5.9 out of 10 Rotten Tomatoes 93 oh
that's like I can see which Camp
Sydney's in there she's in the rhyme
Tomatoes count I just thought that like
I watched it and I remember thinking
like I feel like it's kind of a cool
idea but also I remember the acting was
like really bad yeah and I was like
well I don't know if it's bad but it was
just like I don't know that's definitely
the killer for me with a lot of horror
films where it's like I I hear a lot of
synopsis for a lot of horror films and
I'm like that's an interesting premise
yeah but the problem is at least most of
the ones I've seen the execution the
execution is just so yeah [__] like
it's it's like the acting is and again
like that's why like hereditary was so
scary because Tony Collette was such a
good actress in that you know you can
get around that uh YouTube Summer
you know actually unlocking another
memory you know maybe I watched that I
thought was actually pretty good or like
it was kind of funnily good but the
Invisible Man have you seen this one oh
yeah yeah I've heard of that one he
literally just terrorizes people with it
it's like YouTube prank gone wrong times
a hundred I think you could right it was
good it was good I think it's good yeah
I think I remember I liked it and I
thought that it was good like I'm trying
to remember if I liked it yeah no no it
was good it was good uh it was like
actually intense yeah because the whole
point of the tension right right so let
me frame the film from the beginning
okay uh so this girl I believe dated
like a super super smart guy right and
uh
she breaks up with him and I believe
that you know the breakup wasn't going
didn't go well but for one reason or
another she's really really scared of
this person right and then weird things
start happening in her life and it's to
the point where she thinks that uh
either like a ghost is [__] with her
or someone else is [__] with her life
to the point where her life just goes
just spirals downwards and she is
convinced that her ex has something to
do with it and people are like no you're
[__] crazy you're [__] crazy and
and we don't and we don't know what is
really going on behind the scenes until
it gets revealed right and uh that's
that spoiler territory uh but the name
of the movie gives it away yeah I feel
yeah
it's called The Invisible Man yeah is it
actually yeah it's called The Invisible
Man perhaps the one the culprit is in
the title but but I felt like the the
way that like why that movie was good at
least for my memory again this is years
ago was that it was like it felt
helpless yeah because this guy's so op
yeah yeah because oh no I just I just
remembered why it was it was called that
because her ex is dead
oh
this is what this is like I gotta watch
that movie again
I'm hearing it out of context I'm like
what no one was a great horror film
Gordon Ferrari okay yeah it's a great
movie what a great movie but again like
that's that that also like further
proves my point of why like a lot of
again Japanese horror is good it's
because it's like again that idea of
helplessness yeah right like in like the
garage and like the ring and like One
Missed Call is a [__] terrifying film
the Japanese one the American one is
[__] they like completely botched that
one but the Japanese one is like
genuinely terrifying man it's again it's
because of this idea of like the the
unknown right yeah I don't know what the
[__] is terrorizing my life and killing
me and killing all of my friends yeah
I'm gonna get to the bottom of it and
then we're gonna [__] around and find
out what about if like somebody was an
invisible man and all they did was cut
your nails perfectly every single night
in your sleep and you wake up in the
nails
you know they're there every night have
you ever had that feeling have you ever
had that feeling where it's just like I
don't know something you wake up one day
and just something in your room or
something is just off and you don't know
if you just have [__] memory or if like
something is like all your partner is
terrorized yeah I mean I'm currently in
that phase again where I'm falling
asleep to listening to like cave stories
I don't know why because yeah it's been
a few months so they've they've made
more videos there's people who talk
about it and every time I go to bed now
and I'm listening to that like someone's
dying in a cave I'm like did I lock the
door
hopefully I locked the door why are you
listening to that before you go to bed I
don't know it's like these guys because
all the horror channels like Credit
World credits do they're so monotone
right yeah they're never like hyped up
about like they're not like [__]
YouTubers yeah you will not believe what
happened in this cave it's always like
in this cave on January 14th oh yeah two
kids went in and one guy came out this
is the story about the deadly cave oh
known as the the flocky wacky cave
I'll tell you what I've been listening
while falling to her sleep recently it's
uh yeah uh I've been listening to I
guess science and uh physics videos yeah
all the time and I this is one this is
gonna sound so bad right it's gonna
sound so bad because there's this one
YouTube channel I think it's called
history of the universe where he breaks
down some like Concepts to do with
physics uh and and uh puts like a really
really interesting story into it and
gives like really interesting metaphors
and basically goes through the entire
history about how this discovery was
made and how we came to discover let's
say our perception of how time works can
we time travel backwards and forwards he
basically goes through everything
um and it's super super interesting
because a lot of the times so many sort
of physics yes you actually you actually
uh just you actually uh uh said it
perfectly it's like basically the
summoning salt of physics because I've
heard a lot of Pythagoras
a lot of stuff and then Kepler came in
and so we're gonna clip through time
right now we're gonna go to the fourth
dimension
um yeah and uh because a lot of stuff
that he talks about I already know
because I'm I'm super interested in this
stuff anyway but the way he portrays the
information is just super super
interesting and for some reason helps me
get to sleep like that I discovered him
when we were touring America and for
some reason whenever I put a video on
and his all of his videos are like at
least 50 minutes minimum right and Misty
50 50. so it's like 50. really this is
something yeah yeah it's literally the
summoning salt of physics right and I
I'm I just like for some reason his
voice is so calming that I get invested
in his story and then about 20 minutes
in I'm just like conked out I wake up
this entire playlist is just done right
and so every turn up knowing one fifth
of the physics yeah yeah so every time
he releases a new video it takes me
about three weeks to get through it
because I'm like I
keep falling asleep I'm like [__] this
was such an I want to know how this
video ends I need to I like I need to
see the entire video because it's a
super interesting story I get invested
and then even though I'm invested I fall
asleep so I'm like this is a night this
is a night yeah I've had that so often
with like falling asleep to like
veritasium videos or like yeah videos
it's just like it's it's the tone at
which they talk at yeah and the kind of
slow pacing in nature and like you know
it's obviously just like the lack of
like [__] YouTube sound effects and
[__] yeah yeah right where it's like oh
this is just like it's nice it's just
it's like someone's just talking to me
and just yeah I sleep you know yeah I
don't know what it is something about
here here people talk about just like
physics Concepts or just like because
there's no there's no volume change yeah
no no watch one of my videos it's just
like bro it looks like a [__] seismic
seismic yeah you can't like you can't
tell me this episode is sponsored by
vessies have you guys ever seen a single
photo of me Conor and gone recently that
you've probably seen us rocking a sick
pair of vessi shoes there is nothing
that vessies cannot solve we travel to
Thailand vessies we travel to Hawaii
vessies anywhere we go we wear our
vessies we're SIM for vessels way too
hard we do because they are 100
waterproof great for the unpredictable
Spring weather and vessels will have
your feet dry on the wettest of weather
comfortable and stylish sneakers that
you can wear every single day not to
mention they're made from dime attacks a
dual climate knit material that keeps
you cool in the summer and warm in
Colder Weather it doesn't feel like it
should be waterproof but it is and they
are comfortable durable and breathable
no matter what the situation no matter
where we go we always wear our vest is
because we know we're gonna get a good
pair of shoes there's also an added lug
rubber outsole for extra grip in
Slippery wet conditions and an added
material layer for extra warmth in the
cold so you can check out the vessies
and other styles at vessi.com trash test
get your vessi sneaker and size you want
now and use code trash taste for 15 off
your entire order this episode is
sponsored by better help Joey your 30s
is coming up man dude don't say that and
a lot of things must be a lot of things
must be going through your mind right
now oh tell me about it man it's uh it's
terrifying honestly you know a lot of us
can feel that maybe our lives are
changing really fast and we've lost
track of who we are and that's why at
one point I actually turned to talk
therapy like me the boys we're all
complicated people and talk therapy can
help you deepen your understanding about
yourselves and that's where better help
comes in better help connects you with a
licensed therapist who can take you on
that journey of self-discovery from
wherever you are in my experience a lot
of people found the idea of talk therapy
rather daunting especially guys but
sometimes just having a space where you
can talk freely with someone will give
you a different perspective and that's a
great think about better help it removes
that daunting barrier and just makes it
really accessible for anyone who wants
to get into it better help is entirely
online designed to be convenient
flexible and suited to your schedule
just fill out a brief questionnaire to
get matched with a licensed therapist
and switch therapist anytime for no
additional charge and I want to
reiterate from myself and the boys that
this isn't meant to be a solution to all
the problems in your life it's just
meant to help you find the best person
that you are so discover your potential
With Better Health visit betterhelp.com
trash today to get 10 off your first
month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash trash after the
episode but yeah junjito that anime just
watch it I haven't I've watched this
video I've watched a few episodes yes
which ones did you watch I think the
first couple of ones I watched all of
them why holy [__] when I was um getting
ready for the cyclathon I was like
what's something that I can kind of like
stop watching at any point and not feel
like I need to like like excuse like
some shows it's like I hate it if I have
to stop it halfway right yeah because
I'm like man I just want to keep
watching it I'm trying to keep watching
or I wanna if I stop where I am right
now I'm gonna have to backtrack like
five minutes to remember where I was
yeah because normally the episodes end
and they normally kind of episodic yeah
yeah it's like you know so I was I was
just watching it and I was like holy
[__] none of these are good
yeah can we just appreciate this moment
where the boys have watched something
that I haven't watched but I guess the
reason there because you're a [__]
smart yeah yeah
YouTube is he watching 19 Easter guys so
so the reason I haven't watched it is
because I believe this is another
adaptation that's different from the
ginger collection yeah that aired like
five years ago
is this also called the junji Ito
collection I believe no no it's called
the the tales of the Macabre
yeah it's on it's on Netflix so like
nobody nobody [__] said anything
about this yeah
um you you it wasn't in any of your
videos It Wasn't that's what I normally
find out about what's going on in anime
is watching your videos and so like I
remember I think we were at Sumo and
Felix just goes oh have you been
watching this new YouTube thing and I
was like what the [__] this is yeah I
didn't even know Felix was the one at
all yeah and no one's speaking about it
he's like yeah I just saw it on Netflix
and I was like oh okay so I watched it
and I was wondering why no one's
speaking about it yeah oh my God
yeah I I think and I I don't say this
lightly I have never seen it's been
years since I've watched an anime this
bad yeah it it is so dog [__] yeah this
is just further proves this and the
junjito collection which I sat through
the entirety of yeah because I hate
myself like just
like solid evidence you cannot adapt
jujito stuff yeah I think jinjito is
unadaptable yeah I yeah I I have you
read any of his manga no do yourself a
favor like a nice eye cleanse watching
this I feel like how like seeing the
stories portrayed in that light can
never I don't think I can ever see them
as funny ever again sorry not scary
because to me
70 of them were funny the other 30 was
boring yeah yeah like they open up with
this holy [__] this most god-awful
episode of anime I've ever watched in my
life you watch the first episode right
yes don't be like The Addams Family
basically yeah oh Imagine The Adams
Family that's a weak story in the
morning
and for some reason they put that as the
first episode yeah so like everyone
who's watching this has to sit through
this garbage episode well they did that
with the junjito collection as well they
opened up with like the kid who like
curses everyone yeah and I'm like this
is a [__] story like why would you open
up with this so then you you [__] you
open up this anime right and holy [__]
you get greeted with the the intro song
it's like it's like it's like they were
paying someone to miss because the
opening song is a [__] like screamo
metal song yeah how is that horror how
does that how does that at all get me in
the mood for horror like all of jinjito
is things like you know climactic kind
of like slow build like quiet right yeah
and it's like you have like this guy
it's like oh no we're gonna visit my
family grave and then he goes
get ready for the anime yeah and then
you just start the stupid Adams Family
[__] and it's not even remotely scary
it's just [__] weird like I don't
know as a song it's fine but just don't
it was the worst mix and match yeah
there's a [__] sense and then like I
was waiting for the iconic episodes or
like the iconic stories yeah so one of
the most iconic episodes which uh you
you know told me off camera was uh the
one with the balloon heads yeah that
[__] was so funny and that is like
normally looked at as one of his you
know that's a fan favorite story you
know one of one of one of uh the short
stories that people very much like and
very much portrays the jinjito style and
I remember telling that to Connor he was
like I found it [__] hilarious
because in the show they're like well
honey it looks like everybody outside is
being turned into balloons and he's like
well I'm off to work
right away
he just walks outside and [__] dies
even though he just made an observation
that there are murderous balloons
outside that's that's what you have to
understand about ggito though like no
one I think the person who takes junji
Ito Stories the least serious is jinjito
himself oh which is why like I I like I
don't know if they just misunderstood if
it was meant to be because like in the
same [__] balloon thing the
end is like the girl the main girl who
is following right she so everyone
outside has been for some reason has
been turned into murderous balloons and
when you die you also turn into a
murderous polarity yeah I there is no
more context that is it yeah and they
just they like grab you by it there they
have like nooses attached to the bottom
of the balloons and they just go and
hang you yeah I imagine it's terrifying
in the manga in the anime it's [__]
it's always settling in the moment yeah
it's it's like his his stuff isn't
terrifying it just is just unsettling
yeah a 99 of that is just to do with his
art because right right his art is in
[__] credible right to the point
where if you don't portray I've seen the
art looks amazing yeah yeah he's his art
just evokes the best way I can describe
it is that it's it just evokes emotions
yeah right and unless you translate
those emotions like his like singular
pen scratches that he does the way he
Shades everything there is no way to
translate this feel this still like
painting that he's basically made into
like an animated form in my opinion yeah
because a lot of a lot of his uh a lot
of his stories uh on paper are pretty
ridiculous because they are they're all
like really absurd which is why it was
kind of it was kind of fun to watch yeah
because then when it was funny it was
quite funny yeah like uh the ending of
the balloon one to spoil it if you care
um there's like that's like a 10-page
shorts yeah this girl is like trapped in
because they you know the The Genius of
this world figured out if you just don't
leave the house you can't die yeah
obviously need to get food anyway her
like dead Brothers like knocking on the
window being like hey I'm out I'm
outside she's like oh [__] for real
opens the door obviously it's a [__]
dead body balloon but how is the body
even [__] talking it's so [__]
dumb there was one story that I kind of
liked yeah the premise a lot and they
just kind of [__] it up right at the
end which one uh the tomb Town one
sounds like Toontown but in my British
accent it's Toon Town as they called it
it's where when people die in this town
they immediately like uh you can't touch
the bodies they just turn into
gravestones yeah on the spot oh yes yes
and it was kind of a really cool concept
because we you know we agreed to this
this idea and you're you know the main
character runs over a girl yeah and then
he's with his sister and like oh my god
well we should do something he's like no
put him put her in the [__] trunk or
barrier like oh okay geez and then they
go into this town they're just [__]
gravestones everywhere and oh it's so
[__] so [__] and then they go to
this house to meet their friend and
turns out their friend they just run
over her sister and then they're like oh
where's our sister's like I don't know
right sister we don't know and then
eventually they throw her in the well
and it turns into the shitty CGI dragon
that looks horrible like ass and it's so
[__] stupid oh it's so dumb every
time like a new jinjito anime adaptation
comes out there's like one percent of my
brain that's like this is the one this
is the one that's gonna change it and
every single [__] time it's just
gotten worse and worse like I thought
the Go movie was bad when I first
watched that I was gonna say I think yo
is the only decent I don't think yeah
after the junjito collection and this
new one I think now it makes okay it
made those it was so bad it makes Joe
look like I'm gonna defend yo because
not this it's not really know that uh so
it's one of the long stories but it's
one of the long stories got adapted into
a movie like no no no animated by Studio
you photable what studio animated
YouTube adaptation and it's the best uh
animated adaptation he's ever gotten and
probably ever will get
um but I would say that the manga itself
had some like incredible body horror and
um that was like one of the standouts
about it you put that on in an animated
form and it's it's not scary I'm gonna
say that it's not scary but holy [__] it
was so much fun it was so funny so the
entire concept of go is basically fish
start invading lands right and how do we
how did they invade land uh there are
sharks and fish and they grow robot legs
yeah they're mechanical legs underneath
I think I've seen the stills of this
yeah yeah you've probably seen the still
of like the shark with the mechanical
legs entering the room yeah yeah that's
a really famous shot yeah so they they
just invade the land and uh I guess fish
have decided to take the Earth back
because they are the ones who rule the
earth now yeah and it's just and it's
just a whole movie about fish
terrorizing people on land with
mechanical legs
um some scientists tried to do some wild
experiments and it goes wrong
and you know it's just tying your brain
off popcorn fun I had a good [__]
time watching that it was like watching
a beach you should [__] watch that
yeah was it was it scary no was it
hilarious yes there was one that was
kind of scary a little bit problem with
the um where they peel the skin off
oh that one I can't remember what that
was kind of fun that was kind of well
[__] yeah yeah because like the
they find out from some of course it's
always an archaeological site where they
move somebody and then turns out that
she just has like 26 layers of skin yeah
and then she like ages or something like
it's like one for every age yeah yeah
and then her mom is like [__]
obsessed with her being like young again
so she starts tearing off her daughter's
face yeah
um but it was really funny in the anime
for like the first half and then it
actually got scary yeah that's one of my
favorite stories of his as well but
again a lot of his is just to do with
his art and the way he sets the tone of
his stories uh because like the balloon
one it's on paper it's just ridiculous
and even like the skin one as well oh my
God this keeps reminding me the other
[__] stories one of the stories was
like hey um You probably watched this
one too it's right like hey um my
brother's making too much noise
so we're gonna hire a carpenter to make
my room soundproof yeah yeah and then
the guy comes in he's like yeah of
course I can make soundproof so he
builds four rooms inside of a room and
one of them is just a tiny tiny ass Cub
he's like there you go it's soundproof
and then his brother just goes between
the walls just menacing him yeah and
that's it and then he like lays like
[__] oil and grease in it to trap him
and it's like what the [__] is this like
this no no you know what takes the cake
sorry I'm running an even another one
okay there's another story all of these
sound [__] stupid yeah I'll explain
them did you see the ice cream one no I
don't think so have you seen this one
yes
this is snoring it opens up and this is
a guy who drives an ice cream truck and
he's like hey kids in the neighborhood
who wants some ice cream yeah and then
that's like no I call him I guess ice
cream I call him go in the ice cream
truck and then like all the other kids
are in the ice cream truck is like ah
fine go in the ice cream truck okay goes
in the ice cream truck this [__] ice
cream truck goes around the corner with
like the worst goddamn CGI I've ever
seen in your life it was terrible anyway
so it comes out and then kid comes back
and he's like kind of miserable and he's
like I don't know I won't do anything I
just want to go to the ice cream truck
again so he goes in the ice cream truck
again and then a kid comes back and
comes up with his friend his friend
starts turning into [__] ice cream
and then he he stopped licking his
friend and then it turns out that like
everyone in this truck is just old kids
that turned into ice cream and then you
turn into ice cream when you lick the
kid ice cream and then it was just like
what is this [__] and this dad's kid
turns into an ice cream he's like no and
she's like what is this [__] I respect
it like point where it's like I feel
this is just like junjito's like
personal challenge yeah like look at
something in the real world like he'll
look at a chair and be like I can make a
horse I liked it he never tries to
[__] explain his horror no no that's
that's the other thing yeah the guy
driving the ice cream truck what's his
deal you'll never know yeah he knows he
knows it's [__] business yeah is the
other one told me is that the famous
person
Tommy is really [__] good I thought
it wasn't good in the show really I
didn't get it in the show you didn't get
it I didn't get it what do you mean I
didn't really under so she was just like
cursed like her face or some [__] it was
[__] weird yeah well what's the point
of this [__] well try to decipher the
the intricacies the story is hard that's
the thing it's not about it's not about
what it's about because most of it is
unexplained and it's made that way
because as soon as you explain something
it just becomes less scary yeah it's
just opens inside I agree yeah as soon
as you bring the answers so why one of
his most famous works is Uzumaki uh
which that was that was his thing where
he I guess he tried to make something
horrific around this really abstract
concept spirals yeah so for some reason
spirals just start becoming cursed right
to the point where everything turns into
space everything turns into a spiral
like we don't go back to Monkey we go
back to spiral you know that sounds
great yeah I mean you've probably seen
the like one of the most famous shots
from Uzumaki is this shot of like it's
inside like a big like uh shallow uh
Barrel yeah and like that they've it
just appears in the living room one day
and the daughter and the mama like what
the [__] is this what the [__] is this
barrel and they open it up and it's the
husband that's been like wrapped around
inside oh my God they just like
completely de-skinned and everything and
it's [__] horrific and I'm just like
yo how how scary can spirals be however
you see that pattern you're like yeah
[__] is [__] and then you know you
find out like people start avoiding
Spirals and you're like that shouldn't
be too hard and then you realize that
you're in ear has like a spiral in it
and it's just like some of these like
wild [__] ideas where it's like bird
box but you can't see the spiders
there's a spiral everywhere I don't want
to look at the spiders
um and then it just becomes like really
good kind of like Cosmic lovecraftian
horror because he never explains what's
up with the spirals you know you never
get an explanation even in yo they never
explain it yeah why are the fish ing to
terrorize us I don't [__] know they
just are I think just voice acting these
kind of stuff just hurts it I don't know
why yeah yeah
in a weird way kind of takes the heavy
lifting that you your brain might be
doing for you to make this area yeah and
puts it on someone else you can like
listen to them again I think like the
biggest advantage of Junior stories is
just like it it uses its like quietness
to its Advantage so the moment you start
adding anything like voice acting or
music or sound effects it just feels
tacky yeah and I don't know why it could
be it could honestly be the most well
animated thing but the moment you start
to hear stuff like that I feel it just
takes away from the subtlety of it it's
true future like super popular in Japan
people really want to know he's because
I'd say Infamous because I told some
people I'm like oh you've seen Juju
they're like who I feel like if you like
manga you'll know him but like he's not
like a household name or anything like I
feel like if you just like horror as
well because I I I talk to some people
who have like are not into like the
anime sphere at all I talked to someone
who was just like what the [__] is
Attack on Titan and somehow he had read
a jinjaito work just because he was like
super into horror yeah right yeah so
I'll get him into anime yes yeah yeah
start off with horror with yeah a Blair
Witch and which was great because I he
was like he was like I'm really into
lovecraftian Aura but I've read you into
YouTube stuff is there anything else you
could recommend and I was like oh boy do
I have something called uh do I have
something for you called made in Abyss
which I think is the best you know uh
lovecraftian Horror in anime right now
if not ever you know yeah I didn't start
I don't know if it always started off
that way but especially made in the best
season two it's just got in like [__]
movies
holy [__] but like it's what blows my
mind about meeting the best is that it's
just getting harder and harder to
recommend now not because it's getting
[__] yeah not because it's getting
worse but it's getting progressively
more and more weird in a way that I
can't really convey with words you know
it's really difficult to explain season
two yeah yeah season two is a weird one
like it was great but it was also like
what the [__] did I watch like what am I
watching so many times I have to
backtrack being like hold on I need to
hear that explanation yeah yeah yeah and
you know that's that's what I personally
I love the direction I made in this two
is going where it just gives me this
like creepy it it [__] with you it
[__] with your emotions in a way that
few pieces of media can because you
can't really describe how it goes about
doing that all it does all you know is
that it is doing something really weird
and making you feel really uncomfortable
and weird things and you can't really
explain why it's doing that Susan season
two maybe give up on the fact that
they'll be a good ending yeah
[Music]
maybe there's a chance that it could be
positive but at the moment I saw meaty
in season one I was like oh no no no
this is gonna be bad I think this is
really good though if you haven't
watched it watch made in Abyss um it is
[__] weird yeah check it out what
would you say then because this is
always a point of contexture what would
you say is the best horror anime
in terms of like not in terms of
scariness but in terms of what the genre
has to offer entertainment yeah another
one
I don't even find another funny I'm not
about a [__] funny man holy [__]
those last two episodes are the last
episode oh my God that's the last two
words for the the last two episodes of
another is a horror classic
I always recommend
um
what's a [__] called in Japanese uh
cheeky
cheeky shiki's normally one she is good
yeah when they cry in English
yeah Hiroshi oh Higurashi is good for
the first two seasons and then from
season three just turns into a slice of
life I mean I did actually finish a
garage I've only watched the first
season which is bad I know because all
the answers come in like the season too
yeah I also did a oopsie and watched it
dubbed uh which again which again
because the main character sounds just
like [__] Sonic I don't know why or
how they did that especially the
baseball bats huh why is everyone dying
yeah I don't know I I is there even a
good horror adamant I would say because
I personally love horror anime I'm gonna
google the top 10 horror I would say
personally it's a tie between London
okay okay and magnetic Rose
so uh
not princesses
wait what's the top one okay
this is like Google's this is Google's
suggested Okay Okay Google
Alvin lead alphan Lee uh parasite no no
no that's an action anything with
dubstep automatically is disqualified
from horror yeah another yeah cheeky
sure yeah devil man cry baby which is
Death Note dead man Wonderland a lot of
a lot of what you're saying is like how
they have horror elements I definitely
see the horror elements in something
like Attack on Titan and let's say Tokyo
not a promising start to the list so
this is IGN's Top 10 best horror anime
of all time and the picture they chose
to to you know show the list is a
[__] Death Note
because I died
the absolute state of Horrors top 10
best anime horror of all time it was
posted in October 2022 updated two
months ago two days ago let's see now
theater of Darkness oh yeah yeah is
actually like yeah it's it's crazy
it's horror at least it's it's the queen
bee of horror you know what I mean
Tokyo Ghoul
[Music]
it's like a horror for like the first
five minutes and then it's just like
showing an action show let's go devil
man cry baby accordingly sure number
seven Paranoia Agent
oh
I would I would love that more Society
yeah yeah sex parasites no actually what
do you want five Helsing
housing is more action no it's more
action yeah that was nothing to
horrified me about that oh perfect blue
yes yeah yeah I would actually say Yes
yes again more on the psychological
aspect I've never heard of this one
Boogie pop Phantom but Phantom is I
wouldn't it's psychological I wouldn't
call that it's more of a thriller too
higgy Rashi yeah number one Death Note
Death Note is the best according to IGN
the best horror animals okay if anyone
ever says Death Note yeah of course I
know the best yeah I'm gonna do that for
now High School's the dead Okay high
school but there's got to be a better
run okay so no no there isn't I've
looked into this because I'm like there
must be some good horror out of me and
it's just it just doesn't exist okay so
legit like as someone who's seen like
all those on the list regardless of if
they're horror or not yeah like most
horror anime I would still say Mononoke
and magnetic gross like Mononoke is like
I feel Mononoke is what it would feel
like if they actually really made a good
junjito adaptation where it's like it
has the same like subtleties and
quietness of junjito it's not
necessarily scary it's just super
[__] unsettling yeah because it's
like really quiet and really like no I
wouldn't say slow but it definitely
takes its time yeah and like the
concepts are really scary
um and the Magnetic Rose is like a short
film that was I think spearheaded by
ultimate katsu here
um the creator of Akira but yeah it's
essentially think of perfect blue in
space
that's all you needed
an avakira and the concept of perfect
blue in space and you have magnets it's
[__] awesome and it's super quick
it's like it's like a 40 minute short
film but it's awesome okay heavily
recommend it if you like horror yeah
because yeah go for it I'm looking I was
on Twitter the other day and I saw like
a gif of like a really old Ash anime I
thought damn I'm sick which one and so I
went to the comments and they were like
oh no no don't watch it and then someone
replied to them being like this this
anime is banned in Norway for child
pornography and I was like because
everyone watch it then isn't it Midori
it was kite
[Applause]
and that's also been adapted to uh
Samuel Jackson live-action film yeah
right it has yeah yeah I uh I had to
watch both when I did my review for kite
a while back up uh it's I can see why it
got banned back in the day because I
think it came out in the late 90s I
believe
um it was just like it was one of those
moments where I was like this looks cool
opens the replies oh God yeah uh it's uh
the anime so so the the anime is is
super short it's like two episodes or
something uh but it got banned in a lot
of countries because of that reason
um and then yeah I mean it's it's well
animated it's a really well animated
show and the concept is interesting but
just the execution it wasn't I had to
put yeah one scene in there yeah I mean
there's a there's a all ages version as
well um without the sex scene yeah but I
think it's the one with the sex scenes
that got banned oh okay because of those
reasons nice that they removed the one
without it and then for some [__]
reason Samuel Jackson was like I'ma turn
that into a live action was it actually
him who wanted to do it he's in it
there's no way yeah but I can't remember
it wasn't I don't know if it was like
him like hey guys I guess it's a great
idea but they literally heard that
Samuel Jackson likes hentai
and he's like yeah I don't think he
would like that hentai yeah but uh I had
to watch that as well for the review and
uh itch dog [__] it's really bad
um which won them both the live action
is the anime good the anime I think is
decent again it has a really interesting
concept so the the concept is that like
the the main girl has this weapon where
it's a gun but the bullets explode on
impact yeah that's what I shortly I sort
of give of that yeah yeah yeah solve
like the bullet going in and then they
explode and basically it's like the girl
looking for her uh basically it's like
the it's kind of like a Batman story of
like the girl's parents got killed by
this unknown organization she's on the
hunt to like Kill The Killers yeah um
and so the concept is cool but it's just
like the ending is super [__] weird
again there's that like weird problem
with like the r18 version this happens
so often with stuff I like in anime
where I'm like this is sick and then I
just find out that it's like like in a
Golden Boy where we watched like a few
episodes ago yeah I love that show and
then I saw all the replies to the
comments being like yeah it's Shame
about the manga though and I was like
what do you what happened what happened
in the manga apparently he gets like the
[__] golden showered and like
kidnapped and just turned into a full-on
porno and I was like what the [__] what
the [__] of course it wasn't the anime I
watched why and then I'm like oh well
this thing looks cool it's like oh yeah
it's cool well you're a pedo now
you're a porn addict
now look I just want to watch I want to
watch some more like when I find stuff
that's old I'm like this looks cool and
I find out that like everything anime
that's cool and old is like all [__]
up it's like haha you lit you actually
watch porn which is surprisingly
accurate for a lot of especially older
shows yeah what was going on in the 90s
dude
the 90s OVA like era they were all
unhinged yeah there's so many shows
there were just so many shows that came
out in the 90s that were just like I
couldn't see why anime had this
underground kind of Aura around it
because you could just discover like
this grossly like yeah yeah like a lot
of it was like just an overabundance of
violence and Gore and like over
sexualized you know what's the best
horror anime
it's crazy how now it feels like like
everyone you know I think you have like
redo of a Healer on that weird [__] in
anime and everyone's talking about how
like dude it's so [__] up it's so
gross it feels like damn I mean I feel
like we really [__] tamed down though
compared to what we they were releasing
I think video of a Healer is worse if
I'm being honest I think so I don't know
just like I don't know is it because
it's like conceptually I will say
something to do with the art Styles now
because I weigh more like vibrant and
yeah like soft that it feels way I don't
know why when I watch this 90 [__] and
it's all grungy and it's all oh dude it
feels way grosser yeah yeah way like
worse even though weed over here's like
oh [__] it's also it's also because as
well like especially shows like you know
like genocyber or like violence Jack or
like any of the like really [__] gory
90s the problem is is yeah one it's less
saturated so it feels more like dark
it's always darker less vibrant yeah and
also they're way [__] better around
has this one scene where it's like 120
frames per second guy's head exploding
and I'm like this is like too much d ude
I pretty much the first sick t-shirt
the reason why I think uh redo of healer
is worse is because you know viscerally
you know and I think the things that
happened in 90s ovas are yes more [__]
up on paper but I feel like I don't know
I already know I'm just I mean yeah
ridiculous yeah yeah I'm not I'm not
saying that rid of garbage you're [__]
up but like I don't know the thing the
thing that the big reason why I just
couldn't really get into video videos it
was like just
yeah he was just like the biggest this
is just obviously the most like Power
Trip yeah like Intel fantasy two that
you can get whereas I look at a lot of
90s ovas and I was like yo these anime
just do some sick stuff yeah man yeah of
course it's [__] up of course it's
like hyper violent and [__] but holy
[__] someone was dedicated to that cross
oh yeah yeah definitely and in redo
vahila it's just like all right let's
just take the most incel power fancy you
can possibly get and uh of course you
know I don't really take it seriously
because it's just so far up the field
I'm just like I just don't know it was
so comedic for me yeah yeah exactly
right exactly right it just it just I
just could not take that [__] seriously
at all so what you're saying is if read
over healer was as well animated as Gino
sibo you would hate it less
and what I'm saying is I would rather
redo the Healer just be a hentai then
pretend you know I I would rather just
be a Hands-On like genuine genuine well
you know at least like I I would
generally rather video just be its own
thing have a hentai how is it that if
breed over here was a hentai I'd feel
less guilty to watch it how does that
make sense because it pretends like it
has a plot yeah that's the thing right
that's it pretends like there's
character development and there is an
ongoing port line and that's the thing
that bothered me the most about redo of
a Healer it's like I was trying to watch
rants on like crunch around yeah
or just don't need don't like don't do
it at all don't do it at all
yeah I was scrolling one of those
websites and I um saw a new uh cultured
anime had been released yes and it was
just [__] Red Riding Hood being
smashed by the wolf
and I think that was the whole premise
but the wolf was like had like rizz
I like watched it because I was like I
wanted to see how how possibly they
could sell this Grandma what big risk
you have it was like no no it was like
the wolf was like it was like trying to
like Smooth talk it was really [__]
weird and uh let me uh in the second
episode was like it's something even
weirder let me see what it was real
quick
okay oh my God yeah just I don't know I
feel like the I think like the biggest
problem with a lot of horror anime is
just like a lot of them just do not
adapt yeah into animation like they're
fine in manga format yeah or you know
even light novel format like game format
but just something about anime it just
makes it fantastic little scary I don't
know why yeah do you know what I love
like when when there's when you're just
watching an anime that's not a horror
anime but they'll just be this really
scary episode in it kind of what is it
oh my [__] let's see I thought it was
like when you said the wolf right I
thought you meant like someone dressed
up straight up a wolf and the second
episode was like Alice in Wonderland
being smashed by like I think like a Mad
Hatter or something bro the hentai this
year has been straight ass yeah you've
got no good [__] yeah I have not
watching other than the hentai episode
Joey like like anime uh hentai is going
down the same route Joey just stop
watching yeah
Goblin [__] this year as well there's a
goblin one that came out [__] Goblin
sled just rude are you telling me that I
are also being over [__] exposed to
Instagram
that's what it feels like oh my [__]
god no because like that shit's invading
anime now as well because like I you
know I did it not uh [__] like I did
I did a video recently on like an anime
and it is an anime it's called Uh my uh
my life is uniquized dog
I've heard about this one and it's it's
a show where a guy for some reason wakes
up and uh he wakes up as a dog and his
high school Crush picks him up and
adopts the dog yeah and you know it's
it's an edgy anime so I initially I
thought he was just I've seen this in
the uh before like POV you're with a
girl and she's exercising or something
like that yeah so I thought it would
just be I thought that him being
reincarnated as a dog would be just like
a reason just for some very interesting
let's say anime cameras it's a POV anime
it's kind of a peony
um and then you watch episode one and
then you realize oh like this girl
inukai this girl she likes the dog like
she really likes the dog no no God no oh
it's it's not even like it's not even
like a uh reincarnated dog it's not a
it's it's not a person wearing a dog
[Music]
hasn't gone that far yet but it's it's a
harem it's happening
the dog and the girls and it's how many
what it's like three or four and
Counting right now
oh it's it's like I I watched it and I'm
like this that's it yeah you know that's
not my line you know that is terrifying
though this is my line right now I still
I thought it's it's Red Riding had been
grailed by the wolf was bad it's
terrifying because this is not the first
time we've had a concept like this in
anime because a while back we had dog
and scissors yeah this one goes this one
takes just like but this just seems like
if dog and scissors went down the entire
out all right I'm gonna say one thing
that happens in the manga yeah
breastfeeding
hey yo who and who who is breastfeeding
who the dog the dog is being breastfed
by one of the girls and
no no no no no hold on
why in the [__] would you breastfeed a
dog we're a long way from Texas we are a
long way from Texas no reason what you
as a human being have is a need to
breastfeed a dog there's no wolves oh
hey good to know at least the anime has
a dolphin just make porn
I kind of wish they did
I can't believe this is an anime yeah I
I I I saw this I saw the screenshots of
it I'm like oh sick new hentai just came
out yeah and then people are like oh no
it's being streamed you thought well you
said you thought it was a sick enter no
I was like
and I was like all right people are
talking about this hentai sure and then
everyone was like no you can watch it on
streaming sites I'm like yeah it's crazy
how you literally just say hentai and
everyone like absolutely just is
immediately cool with like Giga [__]
up [__] yeah yeah because I mean you say
anime because at this point it's like
it's not a surprise yeah at this point
we've had no idea I'm done already just
done like I'm I'm I feel like okay I
feel like there should be a line between
anime and hentai right because anime it
gets aired it's it's getting aired on TV
there are like there are some barriers
but there aren't as aren't as many
barriers as some of the stuff you see in
hentai you know hentai you have to go
out your way to find hentai and also
because of that there's you know it's
it's kind of like mixing porn with just
normal media okay it's of course there's
a place for that stuff yes I I feel and
by
by reducing and kind of like getting rid
of the barrier as much as anime has
recently it's getting harder and harder
to distinguish the [__] up things that
is happening in anime versus what's
happening in Enzo I mean I was thinking
that when issues local reviewers came
out yeah I was like bro this is how is
this being aired like I'm like the the
Monger is fine because it's you know
it's published by like uh a publication
that's more oriented towards like yeah
manga right so it's like whatever it
fits in there who cares right but then
when they started really when they
started
and I was like oh they they're keeping
everything in yeah oh [__] okay why is
this not on this website that's a bold
move yeah I I respect it I respect it at
the time I respected it but now I see
unikai's dog I'm like this is the exact
moment where humanity went on the wrong
path okay if this led to unikai's dog we
have gone down the wrong timeline right
now yes if issues
oh this never would have happened if
harambe never got it I'm just saying it
right now none of this harambe would
have saved us none of this would have
happened if I didn't get a shot like
straight up like yeah
huh what is this airing right now it
just finished airing oh it's finished it
just finished it was airing in winter
season you know as soon as you know I
was fine with the degeneration what were
people saying on YouTube about this
thing we were fine with the degeneral I
was fun with the degenerate stuff and to
be fair I'm still fine with the
degenerate stuff you know but as soon as
we started touching our dogs
literally with inequalized dogs that's
why I was like okay anime has gone too
far now
what are the top comments to like an
anime recap of this is nah bro what is
this crying face
the fact that it's like POV as well is
just like even more unsettling because
yeah that means this was made with a
potential demographic in mind that like
there are there are a number of people
regardless of gender who looked at this
and went hell yeah this is my fantasy
right here dude now I can finally live
my dream of being recondidated into a
dog this is breastfed this is really
tough for me as a human being because I
am very anti-censorship and anything you
want to do at the same time I'm like you
just didn't have to make this yeah I
just didn't have to I I don't know how
we can not censor you without without
just without figuring out a way how I
can just get you to not [__] like
this I'm not gonna ask you that I'm not
gonna ask you to delete the Tweet but it
should have stayed
Force being able to delete your work
yeah but how
this should be on a hentai website like
a soft like in the in the vanilla
category of like yeah it's it's whatever
he did some [__] nice [__] happens
yeah yeah
this is getting Yoshi lucky episode
three and four that's that's that's oh
are we yeah [__] it and we're getting
more five and six it's been a match two
I do miss the high school for the dead
days though you know oh my God the order
I get a piece the older I get the more I
realize yeah that was a classic it's a
banger that was a classic show man I
owned that on Blu-ray did you really I
don't even have a Blu-ray player
I collected anime Blu-rays just because
I liked like collecting the physical
media yeah yeah yeah I never had
anything to watch it on you're like
because I'm thinking back and I was just
like there is no other anime like High
School of the Dead no that just has so
much
care and attention being put into equal
parts of just action and just being
[__] horny normally it's like you
just are either it's a really really
[__] horny show and that's the only
reason you're watching it
I never remember the episode is this the
one made by the Death Note guy yeah yeah
yeah no no no no no no no it was
directed by the same guy that directed
the anime the author's dead yeah who who
for what high schools are dead oh oh
yeah
yeah but the same guy who directed High
School the dead direct to death note and
season one of Attack on Titan as well
all right yeah yeah yeah which is which
is why so this manage doesn't miss this
man doesn't miss coded the fact that he
could make High School of the Dead as
memorable as it is even though it's the
[__] dumbest plot line and it's just
there to be horny but yeah the action in
it just slaps so he's still a hood
classic oh man
that that [__] scene with the boob
Matrix he was ahead of his time that
seed is still etched into my mind to
this day it's like anytime I want to
feel like a teenager again I just pop on
that scene I'm like I'm gonna shoot a
rifle through a pair of flopping tits
while using another pair of tits as
Leverage
you can't make that [__] up yeah so good
I'm do I remember how it ends no no do I
care also no imagine if we got the
director to Direct One Punch man again
oh my God yeah that would be incredible
am I am I crazy is season three coming
out it's coming out yeah okay I didn't
imagine that I believe the rumors are
that studio mapper have got the last how
how do they have everything I don't know
bro they're like Thanos right now
they're like another one for the
collection another classic Adam yeah
it's the same yeah I don't I don't know
how they're collecting everything I
think they're taking a lot of like
chainsaw man was like a big risk for
them because they actually like funded
it themselves so that's why they have a
risk sorry that was not a risk I mean it
was it's something new that most anime
Studios haven't done they haven't funded
their own anime [__] big brain yeah
and of course it's kind of like It's
gotta have paid off but that's kind of
the reason why chainsaw man has had was
able to have like I guess like 12
different endings and the insane [__]
yeah
insane that was such Overkill but man I
was living for it yeah like speak okay
going back to something we're talking
about earlier speaking about horror
anime and just the lack of it one thing
I always find interesting is when
there's like a series that's not a
horror series but then they have like an
episode that's just really [__]
terrifying or like really really scary
in itself right example
um one of the examples that I always
or which SpongeBob website at the when
they get stuck at the
um their place in Bikini Bottom when
they get like when they go down the oh
the the down the corner yeah
um I've not seen a single SpongeBob so I
I have I have no I have no horse in this
race I have no horses
now one episode that stands out to me is
uh there was an episode of like Ghost in
the Shell
Standalone complex yeah [__] [__]
insane anime it's basically
cyberpunk before cyberpunk existed
I had a memory
I'm sorry did we decide or do you want
to finish yeah
it's been so like so much Ghost in the
Shell there's like a plot point where
they find the guy and they're like how
do you have so much money he's like well
I just took every extra Yen that
happened during every Bank transaction
off the top and I was like in my head
I'm like what like every Bank trend is
actually yeah yeah because it would be
like millions of boats yeah yeah just
take one yen from all of them or
something or he would take the like it
was so [__] stupid man that's [__]
fine he was like that's how I'm a
billionaire and we're like oh my God
never thought about that funny I could
do that I could take one dollar off the
top of every bank one more like one cent
right it was something like yes yeah one
yen from every bank transfer yeah yeah
it seem like he was a giga brain dude
I'm so sorry I don't know why I haven't
okay no that was that was that was I
like that episode actually I like that
one too yeah uh but there was one
episode where they were trying to find
the serial killer and I don't know why
this scene always sticks out with me
because the smiling guy not The Smiling
guy there's that was also terrifying
[Music]
series but there was this one uh episode
where okay so it basically follows like
the whole concept of ghosts in the Shell
imagine cyberpunk that kind of world but
you follow a police squad like a like a
police squad that's basically the core
concept and it's all like episodic kind
of episode so every episode has a
different storyline that's kind of
self-contained uh and in this one
episode they are looking for this serial
killer
and the way that the zero the the serial
killer the serial killers MO is that he
loves to skin his subjects alive
um and the thing that he does while
doing uh the thing that he does while
doing it is since it's in a cyberpunk
like world what he does is that he jacks
into the girls uh he he skins girls by
the way he jacks into the girls that
he's about to skin and transmits POV
what he's looking at to the girls
wrestlers I don't remember this so what
happens is he transmits his POV to the
girl's retinas so the girl can't close
her eyes and he will skin them alive
while the girl is watching herself being
skinned alive live and the the
terrifying thing is they never show
anything in this in in this episode they
never show anything it's just the
description of the crimes itself and
there's one scene where
um they're watching one of the
recordings of the girl being skinned
right and all you see is just all you
hear is just the sound of this happening
the screams and one of the guy running
out and just throwing up and that just
that [__] terrified oh yeah it's the
the fact that it didn't show anything I
think kind of even made it worse right
that was that that that whole episode
has just stuck with me so strongly not
because the content itself is terrifying
but just like the whole idea of that
[__] happening I think yeah as you said
like it's the fact that they don't show
what is happening yeah and they show the
before and the after yeah is like
because like that reminded me as well
like uh like one of those scariest
scenes in uh perfect blue yeah was the
one where uh oh was it perfect paprika I
forgot which one it was but it was um it
was like a movie yeah it's one of the
Satoshi con films but it's like the one
where like the guy goes into the
elevator
um and there's like a radio just playing
yeah and and I think the concept was
like the killer like leaves behind like
a a radio or some kind of object in it
to like notify that oh he's about to die
yeah and it's This brilliant scene of
like Satoshi Khan not actually showing
the murder happening but he shows the
before of the guy going into the
elevator seeing the radio him getting
terrified and the door closes yeah and
then the next moment is the door opens
and he's already dead yeah right and
it's this idea of like it's not showing
the Gore as it's happening it's showing
like something [__] happened here
yeah but we're gonna leave it up to your
imagination because your imagination is
probably gonna just you know expand upon
the [__] upness yeah which makes it
even more terrifying right and like
that's so hard to do yeah but I feel
like a really good director like saying
like oshimamura for uh Ghost in the
Shell yeah yeah so good at doing that
yeah
um and yeah because I remember that
scene as well and like like another like
not not scene but another like character
that [__] terrifies me
um Johan from monster
he is by far the best anime villain to
be written he terrifies me and you never
do you ever like really see him do
anything like [__] up like gory or
anything like that but like just I don't
know he throughout all of monster
whether you read the Manga or watch the
anime he is you can feel his presence
everywhere right and I don't know how
the author was able to just convey that
everywhere you just feel his presence
kind of like a ghost and just the his
the idea of him as a character also is
just [__] terrifying that it's it's
kind of like kind of like the [__] that
keeps you up at night that's just such a
good series yeah yeah and that's why
he's the ghost the dub is really good as
well yeah the dog is really dub is great
Johan sounds terrifying in the job yeah
yeah Johan is terrifying in the dub and
what what's great as well is that even
though you as the series goes on you
find out more and more about his
backstory you never find out enough that
it stops being terrifying right and it
it goes all the way up until the very
last scene the very last page of the
manga I I just I just remember it
because I'm like how are they gonna end
this and you don't remember it well
Conor's not the type of person that
remembers something after you finish
watching it we've we've established this
already but it ends in the most like
perfect and yet terrifying way where
Johan poses a question I guess and it's
just like okay that just somehow just
tied oh yes everything together and I
know I'm just like this oh my gosh 70
episodes It's been a long time since I
read the Manga but yeah it makes me look
very very monster
I want to watch ghosts in the show too
because I don't remember anything yeah I
don't remember a lot about ghosts in the
show but I just remember that like it
the only thing I remember is uh in the
latest goes to Michelle in 2045 I think
it was called uh just [__] kusanagi
back flipping up the stairs
which is the [__] whole hilarious CG
you've ever seen in your life they made
a new one on Netflix yeah yeah yeah CG
is oh my God her just backflipping up
the stairs is so funny like actually bad
actually about like Attack on Titan yeah
was it was I the only one that found
episode six of cyberpunk edge run is
kind of like scary as well just the way
it was directed
[Music]
oh no
oh oh that episode yeah oh yeah I think
it's it's easily one of the best
episodes in the show oh I think it is
like by Far and Beyond the best episode
in the show I think just like even just
like the last five minutes of it I don't
know incredible yeah I just found the
way that they portrayed cyber psychosis
yeah just I that really like gave me
like an unnerving feeling seeing some of
like your favorite characters like
experience I was like it was cool
because it's like you know normally the
co when you hear about the concept of
cyberpsychosis it's [__] terrifying
on the game it's it's dumb as [__] it is
we got another psycho go and gun them
and then you just go and [__] shoot
them and it never happens to you right
yeah right to you yeah yeah the
protagonist I think I think what what
was so good about that in cyberpunk was
that like it's yes it's scary but also
because you know about the person that
it's happening to it you also feel
really empty inside of like you just
feel sad and you're like ah [__] hell
why yeah like why why did it come to
this kind of thing and then when you
know the that scene happens you're just
left with this idea of like [__]
now I don't want to watch it anymore
this is making me sad but I'm also going
to keep watching it yeah yeah I mean did
you all watch it like one day as like as
well because it's just yeah I mean it
goes so [__] yeah on one flight the
one that I was on with you and now oh
yeah it's like broken by the end
the guy was like do you want another cup
of tea I was like yes
and some tissues please
but not I mean yeah I would love to see
more Horror in anime because that's I
don't know I don't know if you can do it
I mean we've got the [__] dog test
one
that was the most horrific thing I've
ever seen do you think there would be
any live action horror films that would
work in anime
so as in like we've seen a lot of anime
been turned into live action yeah but
what if you took an already pre-existing
live-action horror film and turned into
names do you think it would be as
effective like if you took like say the
ring I'd love like an animated parody of
Paranormal Activity
that's just another it's like it's like
yeah it's like chainsaw man characters
like Dengue why am I someone grabbing my
leg
the problem with like horror anime is
that to me when I see something animated
it's there's always that suspension of
disbelief that's there you know where I
I there's like a kind of safety zone
where even if some really violent and
gory shit's happening there's always
this disconnect where I'm seeing that oh
okay it's animated therefore it's not
real therefore it's not scary which is
why I I rarely find anime horrific
unless it's unikized dog but like
in terms of like live action horror
that's where that's where I kind of like
draw the line because I can't my brain's
just like oh this is real this has
happened so maybe like something say
like you know because there's a lot of
horror movies like live action movies
that you know use ideas of like sci-fi
and fantasy and stuff like that to like
kind of pose it right but I've always
thought like you know like that's very
far removed from reality so do you think
like if it was well animated enough do
you think that would work like as much
as I don't like the movie right like
yeah what if they took like Cloverfield
and then I turned it into an anime no
dude
Sharknado
that would be hype to get UFO table on a
shark I can picture it at him jumping on
the [__] sharks and the tornado to
like kill the big shots like super slow
motion
that'd be hype that would be so hype I
would love to see that
yeah oh you do if we get a science Sarah
Sharknado yeah I don't know I've just
I'm happy to be proved wrong but I've
never found a horror specifically horror
anime that has scared me to the point of
a live-action horror yeah or uh oh I
wonder if that's again yeah but you're
mentioning like just the animated medium
is just inherently less scary yeah yeah
yeah and um I don't know man Courage the
Cowardly Dog was pretty [__] scared
that [__] was terrified that was
animated
I mean that's just like [__]
nightmare fuel at some points man holy
[__] how did they get away with some of
this stuff they can do it in western
content so I wonder why they can't do it
now it seems like now that game of
adaptations are all the rage though sure
yeah yeah we had the Super Mario Bros
movie that I haven't seen yet but
apparently it's popping off yeah and
then Castlevania cyberpunk I think at
last of ours I'm hoping we get more
games true because dude I want Doom
animated so bad a doom anime animated by
Studio trigger because we all want to
forget about the live action right oh
yes exactly that's what I'm saying
imagine Doom animated it's a live action
that bad yes horrendous like Resident
Evil is god-awful yeah Resident Evil the
movies are campy as [__] yeah it's like
the Mortal Kombat movies you ever watch
those yeah I kind of like no I like it
but it's not a horror film no it's a
[__] stupid ass it's hilarious comedy
movies it's an Adam Sandler film that
somehow thinks it's a horror movie I
remember because the Doom movie has The
Rock in it right it does yeah yeah
immediately I can't take it seriously I
don't know like are you talking about
like the original Mortal Kombat movie I
[__] love that movie yeah but that's
because it's like I watched the latest
one I don't know why I did that was bad
I think the original one had its own
unlike oh my God it has this charms yes
the [__] soundtrack oh my God oh my
God what a [__] classic yeah so good
like that was like the Techno 90s in a
nutshell did you watch the second one
though yeah okay that was bad that was
bad that was actually bad they literally
like cut the budget by like a millennium
as far as I know there's only good one
good one right was the first one the
first one yeah yeah I mean it's it's
good I want to say it's good good it's
like it's fun to watch it's entertaining
it's funny and like it's like a 90s
Mario Bros who's funding these movies
yeah I'm just it's just the soundtrack
that just goes like challenge
what did he say is like
some guy good shots Mortal Kombat
oh my [__] god what I want a [__]
hype tune man any fighting games you
think could make good animes
maybe it's basically already that is
basically an anime
is there any fighting games that has a
good story I think the problem is
fighting games have
giant rosters yeah yeah it's like how do
you incorporate them you know well they
tried to do with Mortal Kombat right but
they could only choose a couple of
characters because always as well I
don't know if you feel this way all the
most interesting characters in the
fighting games are like the weird ones
like because you always have the bog
standard characters which are like the
main character dude I want to take Mario
and Smash Brothers like Mario is the
most boring character in Smash Brothers
dude I want a movie of Kuma from Tekken
[Music]
cgiate to everyone yeah it's just
cocaine bad
it's just cocaine it is
yeah I want I wanna oh man man what's
the because I feel like they're gonna
make another Mario movie right because
it did well how do you make the next
story
Island
Yoshi's [__] I mean I haven't seen
the Mario movie but they could
definitely make another Mario movie True
right just do like a Mario Galaxy or
like a Mario Sunshine yeah yeah there
are so many Mario characters and that
I'm sure did not get the spotlight I
mean Luigi's Mansion we need a [__]
Luigi's man Warrior [__] you or Warrior
World Warrior world [__] yeah Mario
played by Danny DeVito
that's that's a movie right in itself
has Mario has Mario ever had an anime
uh yes yes
it also had it also had a TV show
cartoon it also has a manga that I used
to read when I was little and it's been
still going for like 40 years oh do you
know do you want to know one
announcement I saw like earlier today
just made me sigh uh Rick and Morty is
getting an anime
wait what Rick and Morty wait who is
getting an anime oh don't tell me how
does that make sense
you're already animation how do they
well like season seven is obviously
still getting made but there is another
separate I guess non-canon like season
that is getting animated by a Japanese
Studio that is Rick and Morty the anime
[Music]
I'm just like oh
how is that that humor is not going to
translate no it is not gonna try it's
like it's like when you watch Simpsons
dubbed like it just doesn't matter it
just doesn't work
I was asking for this I don't know I
don't it's Rick and Morty fans are
asking for no they're not no there's no
no they're not guarantee bro Rick and
Morty fans fell off because of the
[__] Justin roiling [__] yeah yeah
greenlit I don't know oh what I am
excited about though is the Scott
Pilgrim anime
holy [__] the entire cast as well
I don't know how they're gonna I don't
know how Michael Sarah is gonna be voice
acting but I'm genuinely curious yeah
actually
it's just come out of a [__] anime
character it's gonna be hilarious and
let me go Chris Evans back I mean they
got like the entire cast back and uh
They masakiwasa isn't directing it from
what I understand but they got his
Studio to make oh really yeah yeah and
if there's one Studio I trust to be able
to translate yeah the weirdness uh and
the uniqueness of
um Scott Pilgrim from live action to
anime it's uh it's science sorry yeah
because I that's that's another thing
that's I I do think Scott Pilgrim is
like a one-of-a-kind kind of movie as
well there is no other film that I think
has done what Scott Pilgrim has tried to
do as well as Scott Pilgrim has done
well that's a Edgar Wright film I mean
he's just a brilliant [__] director
well he's a brilliant director that you
know respectfully tries to do something
new yeah every time kind of like
noodling in that sense but and you know
there has been other like kind of like
hey he is like a nerd movie to appeal to
the Nerds you know kind of thing
just like me like well yo he made a
video game he made it hold on let me
turn off Mortal Kombat my favorite movie
is Gamers yeah what Gamers oh Gamers the
one with Adam Sandler and Peter Dinklage
what's uh was it free guy or good guy
free guy free guy yeah that was another
film that was just I didn't know that
was it good this guy hey Gamers uh I
don't have Jack uh yeah Sean was in it
I'm always a bit wary when my cousin
like really likes a nerd film because
he's I don't Justice taste okay dude's
like a [__] brother to me right but
he's he's on the cusp of just like yes
I'm a nerd I like Marvel movies you know
I play video games now it's now it's
into hate on Marvel though now it's kind
of high is it it's in yeah it's in to
head on Marvel and I don't think it's
into hate on Marvel yeah that's
mainstream now what do you mean it's
amazing
hating Marvel movies I mean I've been
doing it for years
so he's like my time is like you were
you were kind of a Brother's Rejoice sir
you were pretentious before but now it's
in oh [__] now it's in dude now you
have to change your stance
Ant-Man Quantum realm is the best
uh yeah it's like everyone no I no one
says nice things about Marvel movies
anymore but is it just because the
quality is going down yeah because it's
terrible yeah I bet yeah I mean I'm I'm
still waiting I'm so [__] happy we
finally get different movies yeah like
the next coming years yeah thank God
if only they did that with there's a guy
anime
the population of Japan has to get bored
with isakai at some point it's Gotta
Have I said that five years ago it's
gonna happen I don't I don't know I
don't know I mean as long as they keep
making interesting isikai Concepts I'm
gonna keep watching I'm I'm Define
interesting
because you know you could say the
vending machine Sakai is interesting
that's that's not interesting that's
just that's just a dog meme this dog one
that's not that's that's not an easy guy
what do you mean yeah
it's more furry actually yeah
okay I mean like isakai is actually very
similar to like the whole comic book
phase that you know Hollywood is going
through where it's it's less about okay
it's okay isakai sells people clearly
want what's the familiarity it's the
familiarity with it and 99 of isekai
[__] sucks ass right but then you get
that that one percent which is just is
generally just isakai Sai just a good
[__] story and a good [__] show
same with [__] comic book movies
right you have you know other comic book
movies and then you are on the off
chance you get something like Joker yeah
no I'm not I'm not denying that like you
know I might seem like the [__] I
just hate all this a guy like guy but Ah
that's me yeah
there's some good essay guy out there
like of course but yeah you know I feel
like the 99 of the [__] ones could have
been replaced with actually some more
unique interesting Concepts that they're
a [__] plethora of those in the manga
and even the light novel world that just
don't get any attention because the guy
is remained in the same [__] world
I'm calling it now yeah we're trying to
get to the point where we just try to
remake other animes and just like but
the the premise is that you you isakai
into that anime
they're not going to say it right so
like a picture of this someone dies yeah
they appear in another world what's this
they've got a book where you write
someone's name and they die in it like
and they just start repeating aspects of
Death Note so at the end of one piece
Luffy actually dies and then he becomes
a Shinigami with Ichigo and uh I'm
telling you in the next three to five
years we'll get an anime that is just
somebody who is another world and
becomes a pirate and there's like a ton
of One Piece references and it's just
[__] dog [__] that just sounds like a
Game Time chapter I mean that's just it
they're just gonna start remaking anime
yeah and just slapping on a nice guy on
it I mean a lot of times I feel like
when I watch an isaka I kind of just
ignore the Easter guys yeah you have to
do that just because it it kind of feels
like I in like 80 80 of that I watched
the Easter guy is irrelevant to the
[__] story of course but I feel like
the author just put that in because he's
just like I need to put say God in my
story somehow yeah or no one's actually
gonna watch or read my work yeah like
yeah I feel like it's kind of almost
kind of like diminishes the value of the
other world inherently because it's like
oh well you know it's that it's not it's
not his world it's we are the main world
yeah it's like whereas Maiden the best
is like hey this is this is the world
yeah yeah characters their world and
that's the unfortunate thing is that
like there are so many like modern
isakai that have interesting like little
bits of Concepts that would easily stand
up on its own yes but the problem is it
[__] you know it it knee jokes Itself
by adding isekai into it because it's a
necessity nowadays yeah like this is how
to get the kids attentions put it in an
Instagram it's like well you know if you
have an interesting concept you can keep
it in the same world you could you know
I think people have forgotten that the
fantasy genre exists you can just start
in that world you know you don't it
doesn't have to come from a different
world you can just start there no I mean
even above that people like I I would
like people to remember that the fantasy
genre uh is more than just the same
starting Final Fantasy Town yeah which
is every fancy and easy Sky anime it's
all the same [__] world and it's just
like fantasy it's like can I copy your
homework it's like it's like copying the
homework from the guy that has given his
homos to like the 20 other people in the
class and everyone is copy from the same
sheet yeah you know because like it's
interesting you mentioned about like the
World building as well because like
you've seen a rising with the shield
hero yeah yeah like one of the biggest
things that pissed me off about writing
of The Shield hero is that it just felt
like the whole world was made around the
main character yeah right like the main
character was obviously like the most
competent and the smartest person in the
world but it wasn't because he seemed
like he was competent or smart it was
because everyone in uh everyone around
him was just [__] stupid yeah it was
like if he said like two plus two is
five everyone be like [__] you're right
yeah yeah all right
Shield hero it's the most used this
class but actually it's impressive how
he's managed to make everything works
and again I feel it's like a big problem
is that like they don't it doesn't feel
like the world exists independent to the
main character yeah it feels like the
world is built around the main character
to make the main character look as cool
and as badass as possible it's like it
felt like it was just like No Game No
Life world but yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's exactly how [__] stupid this
world is yeah exactly and like now
around you and like now that's the peak
of that kind of like stupid power
fantasy has come out which is called
Eminence and Shadow that's like that's
as good as it can get that's that's
that's what happens when you take like
you this this is like a nice guy where
it takes all like the stupid and
overpowered tropes bangs everything up
to a hundred makes the main character as
cringy and as Edge Lord as possible and
it just like it's so stupid and
overpowered that it just becomes fun
again you know right that's like the
peak of the genre that's been done now
Isa guy so now we can do other Avenues
now we can explore other avenues like
taking every immovable object possible
and putting the [__] protagonist into
it yeah yeah that's what I want to see
but
is that what you want to see though I'm
done with it bro I don't know I don't
know I just want to see good shows I've
watched some of your anime back in the
phase of when I would watch anything
this is an anime and there's like
monoliths and that like the main
character had like a cute little girl
that was a [__] cat or some [__] and
they just stayed near the monoliths and
there was a guy in like a top hat and
one of those like uh [__] masks like
the anonymous Oh Black Bullet like
that's it oh yeah how the [__] did I
remember that get that from my dog
man damn it he is the anime man if you
like Black Bullet no it was [__] he was
[__] it had it like the first half of
the first episode I was like okay this
could be interesting this is how I like
and then it just went to [__] this is
how I know unless you've been watching
anime for five plus years at your
opinion on anime is not relevant yeah
it's because I used to think that [__]
was fire and I was like I was like one
year because that's one year into
watching anime and I thought damn this
[__] isn't yeah yeah yeah the best yeah
but that's you could you could replace
Black Bullet with uh akame got killed
you have that phase where
like it's a different length for
everyone but I think everyone has a time
period where you you will not you will
no longer tolerate every anime yeah like
yeah it's the end of the honeymoon
period yeah I think for some people I I
speak to them I'm like holy [__] you've
been in this and you're still going like
eight years strong like how do you how
do you just watch these these guys I
think it's good that's me yeah right
you know you talk about anime and you're
like no it's bad yeah you'll still watch
it which is this insane part yeah you're
out of the question because it's your
job yeah yeah
you're getting paid okay okay here's the
thing though here's the thing okay I no
way would you watch half of these used
car if you weren't getting paid most of
the time I just read the Manga actually
okay because last time
um but some some music I think genuinely
do have interesting like the the reason
I like isakai isn't the iskai aspect a
lot of the times they a lot of them have
like one really cool interesting idea
that they explore for about a few
volumes and then it stops and then
you're like okay I can move on to the
next one now it's not it's not like the
whole the isek iPod it's that one
interesting idea that they explore and
then because it's Easter guys so
disposable then it's just really easy to
like move on from one series to another
because every series explores every uh I
think explores a different thing and
then it's never interesting enough to
hold up for like 10 volumes or something
yeah it's just like yeah I've read it
for like four volumes and I'm done and
then I I can move on to the next
interesting idea
um but like I don't actually I don't
know I do watch a lot of anime but I
feel like I watched less anime than
people think I watch because it's
possible okay so I watch everything when
the season comes out right a lot of that
time I watch that in times two speed
because I [__] have to now because
there's like 50 shows every season uh
but I genuinely only go off and finish
the shows that I find interesting I
think are gonna be good and most of the
shows end up on my end of year list uh
so I end up watching like 20 plus shows
every year which if you if if if you
think about how much people think I
watch I'm sure people think I watch way
more yeah but there's a difference
between the shows I watch and the shows
I finish and I only finish a show if I
really [__] like it oh yeah no yeah
and I feel like that's that's a that's a
big thing because I feel like there's a
reason right there's a reason why the
average score on Mao is like seven out
of ten right because like a lot of
people are like oh people don't know how
to review correctly and I'm like no
you're not gonna go you're not gonna
finish a five out of 10 show I normally
only finish shows if they're 7 out of 10
minimum right see that was the problem I
had yeah even if it was dog [__] yeah I
stuck through all of those until the end
and that's why I'm burnt out see it's it
was only when I could let go of that
feeling of I the completionist side of
you yeah as soon as I let that part go
and I'm just like I'm just gonna finish
what I feel like I tried to do all the
side quests and I found out there was no
end game yeah so like this last season
didn't actually watch anything aside
from villain Saga right that was it that
was all I watched that was one anime
yeah because I've been a song was
[__] incredible but the season itself
pretty [__] actually no actually I did I
did finish one try again [__] oh yes
Trigon was great uh I didn't finish does
it have a good ending what'd you mean
Dragon well it goes in a completely
different direction okay yeah yeah yeah
so have you watched the original watch
the original I thought the ending was
weird Okay throw everything through
everything you know about the original
out the window uh because this one goes
a completely different direction it's
less medic and I would say less
like Western in terms of like it's it's
it leans more into the Sci-Fi it leans
way more into the Sci-Fi aspect which
even just saying sci-fi aspect is kind
of like a soft spoiler if you only are
judging by the original because that
doesn't really come to play until like
halfway through the series but it's less
of uh spaghetti western which is very
reminiscent of the original and it's
more of like here is a weird sci-fi
story in a Sci-Fi world it's more akin
to something like Dune and I I really
like that and holy [__] Studio orange
knocked out the park they don't miss
they don't miss there's a little
spaghetti western huh we don't call
others oh it's because uh the term
originally came from the fact that a lot
of western films were directed by
Italians
oh I literally found this out like two
days ago from a YouTube short so thank
you well you learned something new every
day and I was like that's a [__]
weird way of saying it we don't go like
you know like a Japanese tuna we're like
oh yeah yeah a tuna horror a sushi
Marvel
[Laughter]
is there a good horror anime that we
missed is there any horror movies that
you would recommend uh please let me
know so I could seem like I'm more like
a good husband to Sydney to be like
Sydney I got a guy I got a good horror
movie for you hey look at all these
patrons though look at them all do you
guys like horror films yeah there's so
many of them wow oh my God I can see all
of you guys oh hey but if you like to
support the show then uh go over to
patreon patreon.com trash taste also
follow us on Twitter send us memes on
the subreddit and if you hate our face
listen to us on Spotify and uh yeah
that's been this episode of trash taste
[__] what I just uh I was like we had a
whole themed episode and I didn't
mention Goosebumps once I was like how
did that happen that's that's a that's a
full episode I was like that's a huge RL
Stein the goat that's enough
all right I'll see you guys next week
all right bye
[Music]